this video is brought to you by
brilliance problem-solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach improve
your STEM skills while having a great
time learning at brilliant at org /by
graphics more on them in a bit what's
the first name that comes to mind with
the mention of electricity Thomas Edison
Nikola Tesla perhaps even Benjamin
Franklin yes michael faraday
has every rights you belong on that list
too is it's impossible to imagine a
world without his contributions to
science from chemistry to electricity
from theoretical science to practical
experiments that revolutionized the
world
Faraday's contributions can't be
overstated and there's more to the story
than just success it's also a poignant
tale of how anyone regardless of their
backgrounds their education or their
upbringing can make a real impact
Faraday started out as just an everyday
sort of person from a family that had no
vast fortunes or resources as a child he
often went to bed hungry
he had next to no formal education and
once he did get an apprenticeship in the
subjects that had sparked his curiosity
and determination he started at the
absolute bottom
it's a tale not just about science and
discovery but the power of grit and
determination and a man who at the end
of his life wasn't just remembered for
his monumental advancements but for his
kindness as well
little is known about Michael Faraday's
young life growing up in the area of
London now known as Elephant and Castle
the reason for that is simple
it wasn't the sort of life anyone would
really want to record and his parents
lived the sort of everyday existence
that danced on the edge of abject
poverty we do know that he was born on
September the 22nd 1791 in Newington but
the aforementioned
Elephant and Castle area of London his
father James was a blacksmith originally
from Yorkshire who moved to the south
and ultimately married the daughter of a
sorry farmer a Faraday was one of four
children and life was difficult his
father was ill for much of his childhood
and that meant he wasn't able to hold
steady work oftentimes he wasn't able to
do much to support his family life was
hard and it was the sort of hardship
that meant the family often went to bed
hungry in 1801 the family was actually
awarded public relief for the then
nine-year-old Michael that came in the
form of a single loaf of bread per week
but even in the hardest of times
families can sometimes find a way to
make things work for all the hardship
Faraday still grew up knowing a mother
who loved him dearly and it was during
his childhood that he came to know what
would be one of the biggest influences
on his life and that's religion the
Faraday family belonged to a small sect
called the san domain Ian's they were an
offshoot of the Christian faith founded
only about 70 years before Faraday was
born the sect descended from Scottish
gar sites believed that the church
should be beholden to no one and nothing
but the original apostolic doctrine
their faith was one of a devout and
quiet sort of piety and they practiced
things like a weekly celebration of the
Lord's Supper and feet washing ceremony
accumulating wealth was seen as immoral
and members were expected to share what
they had with other church members who
were in need the sect had mostly
selfless beliefs but there's a few
things worth noting particularly because
Faraday's identification with the sender
Manian sectors something we're going to
come back to you later in his life among
their beliefs was a strict refusal to
pray alongside those of other faiths
even other Christians associating with
those who had been excommunicated was
also a major sin but for now during his
childhood Faraday
association with the church was a
pleasant one he read aloud during Sunday
school he was an active member of the
modest congregation and it instilled a
curiosity about the world around him
Faraday was always bright Charles and
while he once credited as a day school
with teaching him the basics of reading
and writing it's arguable that his
education truly began when he was 13
years old that's when he was sent to
apprentice at perhaps the best place a
curious young mind could find itself a
London book binding shop even though he
started out simply as an errand boy it
wasn't long before the book binder a man
named George Wray bow signed him on for
an eight year apprenticeship and while
he was there he was doing much more than
just running errands he read each and
every book they bound including works
like Jane marsuits conversations in
chemistry and much of the Encyclopedia
Britannica it was the articles on
science force and energy that
particularly captivated the young
Faraday and opens up a whole new world
that would quickly get even wider by
1810 Faraday had joined the city
philosophical society and in spite of
the somewhat deceiving name it was a
Society of young people who gathered on
a weekly basis to listen to lectures on
some of the most cutting-edge science of
the day first Ward a bit to 1812 and
this is when things really started to
change one of the bookbinders customers
was William dance who was one of the
founders of the Royal Philharmonic
Society he was the one who gave young
Faraday four tickets one to each of
Humphry Davy's last four lectures given
at the Royal Institution and that was
when he found a calling that was worth
fighting for
[Music]
by the time faraday headed off to davies
lectures he had already begun two
experiments with what he read about in
the books that had come through the
little shop where he worked it already
built his own electrostatic generator
out of some wood and a few old bottles
and dabbled in his own electrochemical
experiments when he listened to Davey's
lectures he was captivated so captivated
in fact that he decided that this was
where he wanted to be and here's the
thing
there was no reason that Davey should
have given him a second glance he was
largely self-educated from a poor London
family and when push came to shove he
absolutely wasn't the sort of person you
would expect to see accepted into a
prestigious position in the scientific
community still you don't get anywhere
in life without putting yourself out
there and Faraday had the tools to do
exactly that
he took extremely detailed notes during
Davey's lectures then headed back to his
day job and turned those notes into a
bound book which he then sent Davey
along with a rather brazen application
for an apprenticeship but just how
brazen was it
well Davey was one of the leading
chemists of his day and when it comes to
famous scientists through the lens of
hindsight he's really up there by the
time Faraday reached out to him Davy had
already been appointed to the Royal
Institution as a regular lecturer than
ultimately as a professor he would turn
it into a sort of Advanced Research
Centre for some of the era's brightest
and most innovative minds and he had a
slew of credits to his name look back on
his career today and you'll find it's
one full of impressive achievements
including the discovery of how to
isolate sodium potassium calcium and
other alkaline earths additionally and
perhaps of note those of us who loathe
going to the dentist he did extensive
research on nitrous oxide that's better
known as laughing gas
Davy proposed using it as an anesthetic
for minor surgeries though his
suggestion was at the time mostly
ignored instead it became the cool fun
thing to do at English parties Davy was
at a point where he definitely could
have just cast Faraday's application
aside without a second glance but he
didn't perhaps because he was himself a
self-made scientist who grew up as the
son of a
or Cornish woodcarver Devi had to turn
him down at first that was simply no
position open for him but when one of
Davey's assistants was fired for
fighting just a few months later he
reached out to Faraday and offered him
the job
[Music]
today Faraday is remembered mostly for
his work in electricity but he didn't
start out there when he started working
with Davy in 1813 his official title was
chemical assistant at the Royal
Institution that was in March by the
time October rolled around he found
himself embarking on a different sort of
adventure
although adventure is probably being a
bit generous in October of 1813 Davey
and Faraday set off to the continent it
was the chance of a lifetime certainly
but there was a catch the passports for
the group had been issued by Napoleon
and he had made allowances for Davy
Davey's wife a maids and valet nowhere
in that list was anything like a
research assistant or even secretary so
it quickly became clear that if Faraday
wanted to go it was going to have to be
a valet to the trip which only ended in
April of 1815 led to some serious
conflict within the group accounts
suggest that Davey's wife Jane insisted
on treating Faraday only like a servant
he of course took great exceptions of
the role and it fell to Davy to keep the
peace regardless of the conflict Faraday
was exposed to some of the scientific
world's most cutting-edge research in
France they saw chemists demonstrating
the electro chemical nature of iodine
and in Italy they got unprecedented
access to the duke of tuscany 'he's
great lens there they were able to take
a diamond and turn it into carbon which
would probably be pretty awesome to
witness even in our jaded 21st century
world from there it was on to
Switzerland and into the south of
Germany but here's where things get a
little fuzzy the trip was supposed to
continue but it didn't whether that was
due to internal conflict or external
affairs is unclear but it was about then
that they headed back to England and
Faraday retired his valets jacket in
favor of his original post as chemical
assistance there he was once again able
to work on projects that more befitted
his drive including the miners safety
lamp a project that ultimately resulted
in a light source much less likely to
ignite the methane gas commonly found in
mines he worked with others at the
Institute - including a maker of
surgical instruments named James
Stoddart together they were trying to
invent a way to improve the quality of
Steel and through it all Faraday
was still just an apprentice remember
his apprenticeship didn't even end until
1820 and by the time it did come to its
end it was clear that Faraday was just
as much an expert in the field of
chemistry as Davy was it came as no
surprise when in 1821 he was appointed
superintendent of the house at the Royal
Institution it was a position that saw
him being put in charge of the physical
buildings a huge deal considering that
at the time they housed some of the
finest scientific research laboratories
in Europe but just before we continue
with today's video you're watching a
blog video about a scientist so I think
you'll like today's sponsor and that's
brilliant brilliant is a problem-solving
based website and zapped with a hands-on
approach they've got over 60 interactive
courses in maths science and computer
science you've heard me talk about
brilliant before and how they teach you
all of those things but beyond that they
also teach you problem-solving skills
which are practical even if you don't
pursue the sciences as a career learning
how to break down complex problems to
their component parts is pretty critical
in any career path you choose now maybe
you've wanted to learn programming that
you've always been a bit daunted by it
normally I mean it requires you to learn
tedious details of a specific
programming language but really the
bedrock of it all is the understanding
of fundamental algorithms on brilliant
you start by programming a drone with
simple instructions which teaches you
the basic structure of every program
that you're ever gonna write it's all
drag-and-drop exercises which very
quickly get your thinking like a
computer scientist and that's just one
example
there's loads of great stuff on their
platform look brilliants a great
compliment to watching educational
videos like this one and it will really
help you master even complex and
technical subjects so if you want to
support this show and get unlimited
access to all of brilliance in-depth
maths and science courses please head
over to brilliant a talk forward slash
bar graphics and you'll get 20% of their
annual premium subscription let's get
back to the video
the year 1821 was an important one for
Faraday not only because of his new
appointment with the Royal Institution
but also because he married Sarah
Barnett she too was a member of the
sander manian faith hailing from one of
the church's leading London families
less than a month after they were
married faraday performed his confession
of faith and was welcomed into the
church as a fully fledged member which
again might seem like a relatively minor
detail but one that we'll come back to
it was also in 1821 that he made a major
scientific discovery it's not even an
exaggeration to say that this one really
did change the world it started when he
read a paper by the Danish natural
philosopher Hans Christian ørsted he was
writing about his discovery of this
thing called electromagnetism but there
was some difficulty in getting the
theory across in a way that was easily
understood since austat first wrote his
paper and law latin before having it
translated to various european languages
it didn't quite capture all the nuances
of his style which was more naturally
philosophical than naked ly scientific
in fact Faraday himself wrote a very
little to say on M Austen's theory for I
must confess I do not quite understand
it still you might say that Austen's
theory sparked something in Michael
Faraday later that year he set up a
surprisingly simple experiment at the
Royal Institution that proved it was
possible to use magnets to turn
electricity into mechanical energy the
first surviving example of Faraday's
mechanism is one that he built in 1822
and it's essentially a glass vessel
partially filled with mercury we want to
point out here that you don't want to
try this at home mercury is in the World
Health Organisation's
top 10 chemicals that is a cause for
major health concerns it's toxic when
ingested or inhaled so again don't try
this at home
as dangerous as mercury is it's also an
excellent conductor so it was perfect
for Faraday's experiments he took this
mercury fills glass secured a magnet to
the bottom and suspended a wire into it
from above an external batteries and a
current into the wire which created a
magnetic field interacted with the
magnetic core and caused the wire to
spin it was the first electric motor and
if you stop the thing
about all the things that we rely on
today and have relied on for decades
that have electric motors you'll get
some idea of just how monumental this
discovery was it also led Faraday down
another path when it came to the theory
of electricity
it made him contemplate the possibility
that electricity wasn't a fluid after
all like many believed at the time he
envisioned it as a force or a vibration
something that was transmitted instead
of being allowed to flow and that
breakthrough was a huge deal for the
next two decades Faraday worked at the
Royal Institution and set up countless
experiments his work with electricity
was on hiatus for much of the 1820s as
he worked with the British Admiralty to
design an improved optical glass and it
wasn't until 1831 that he really got
back to doing what the world needed him
to do they just didn't know it yet his
work on the theory of electrochemistry
came in that same year when he develops
the ideas of electromagnetic induction
which would go on to become the basic
principle that forms the groundwork of
things like generators and electric
transformers he coins words we all heard
in science classes words like ion
cathode and electrode it's impossible to
talk about all of his theories
discoveries and advancements in such a
short time but there's one more that's
definitely worth a mention it came in
1836 and it's the Faraday cage you've
probably heard of them in the
aforementioned science class and you've
probably seen one but you might not
realize just how important they are the
Faraday cage is fairly simple it
collects and distributes electrostatic
charges across the exterior of the cage
protecting what's in it even if you're
only vaguely familiar with the idea
you've been inside Faraday cage is a lot
they thought cars and aircrafts are
protected by Faraday cages they might
not be worrying about getting struck by
lightning while you're driving along to
Sunday dinner with the inlaws in which
case you might actually be hoping for a
little bit of lightning it's a very real
danger when you're thousands of feet in
the air
Faraday cages are actually everywhere
and while yes they are put in place on
purpose to protect important things like
top-secret and proprietary information
there's also one in your kitchen right
now
the mesh that's over the window and your
microwave that's part of a Faraday cage
that allows you to reheat your leftover
pizza in complete safety by keeping most
of the microwave radiation on the inside
so like we said kind of a big deal
[Music]
while Faraday was conducting no pun
intended his experiments there was of
course a lot going on in his everyday
life and this is where we get back to
his faith in 1832 Faraday had been
appointed to the Deacons office of his
church and it wasn't long after that
that the continued strain of experiments
theories writing and lectures took a
toll on his health it led to him
stepping back of it and he did little
work between 1839 and 1845 in 1840 he
was made an elder in the church it
wasn't just handed to him because of his
scientific work but because he was
recognized as an upstanding and devout
figure in the community
this makes Faraday something of an
anomaly and the scientific community
because it's well known that science and
religion rarely go hands in hands but
Faraday firmly believed that not only
should the Bible be taken literally that
God really did create everything in the
natural world but he also believed that
the natural laws he was working with and
had been exploring were put in place by
God by conducting his experiments
improving his theories he truly thought
he was getting closer to understanding
God's plan or at least the laws that God
had put in place to keep the world
running while it might seem that the
Sander main Ian's would be grateful to
have such a devout elder in their church
it wasn't without conflict we mentioned
that the traditions of the Santa may
nians involved the observation of a
weekly Sunday supper the Lord's Supper
in 1844 Faraday missed one of those
suppers and wasn't just removed from his
position as elder he was excommunicated
for it he has an extremely good reason
for missing the meal Queen Victoria had
invited him to be her personal honored
guest and that's just not the sort of
thing you turned down
he was eventually welcomed back to the
church and in 1845 he once again picked
up this scientific research much of his
work was theoretical exploring the unity
of forces but he also took on a
fascinating and massive project figuring
out how to update and upgrade England's
lighthouses an estimated 10% of his
correspondence involved this projections
he was the one who decided after doing
extensive testing himself that Frederick
Holmes's
of using a carbon arc lamp was the way
to go in 1858 the first electric light
house littered beacon thanks to
Faraday's work between 1864 and 1866
London saw the construction of their
only lighthouse it stands on the
intersection of the Thames and the River
Lea and it's where Faraday oversaw the
testing of new lighthouse technology
even though there's plenty of inventions
we'd know him for today
that was as only one patent he was ever
awarded and that was for a chimney that
would be installed in lighthouses in
order to prevent the combustion of gases
it was designed at the Docklands
lighthouse and it was Faraday who
supervised the monumental task of
electrifying all lighthouses
[Music]
by the time Faraday saw lighthouses
converted to electric lamps he already
knew that his mind was beginning to fail
him by 1855 he had largely retired from
experimental and theoretical work his
attempts at converting gravity into
another force as he had converted
electrical energy into mechanical energy
had failed and he refused to publish any
of his work on the problem he was
offered a knighthood but declined it
saying that he would be plain mr.
Faraday until he died and this is a case
where his refusal say just as much about
his character as his achievements he
also declined an offer of the presidency
of the Royal Society twice and also
refused to work with the government when
it came time to develop chemical weapons
of the Crimean War those who wrote about
him consistently wrote about a humble
and kind person who was more concerned
with his faith and his science than with
awards and accolades he did accept a
small pension from the Queen and in 1851
census records showed him living at the
place he had worked set for so long the
Royal Institution in 1858 Queen Victoria
also gave him you serve a Grace and
favor house located in Hampton quarters
a thank you for all he had done not just
for science but for the country it was
at this house that he died in 1867 there
was just a few thousand pounds that
needed to be distributed through his
will and while he left most of it to his
wife he also left money to miss Savage
the values and faithful housekeeper of
the Royal Institution and to his niece
Jane to the rest of us left quite a bit
of wonderful wisdom including this
thought no matter what you look at if
you look at it closely enough you are
involved
entire universe so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below do not forget to subscribe brand
new videos just like this several times
per week and do check out our fantastic
sponsor brilliance who I'm linking to
you below and thank you for watching
[Music]